I'm Chris cotton I'm here at Connery
sisters roasted Bruce Willis and I have
one question what you talkin about
Willis Willis Willis oh I see what you
did there and I like it
so we will ask you a couple trivia
questions real quick alright do any of
them consist of am I gonna sleep with
Bruce Willis and what year did Bruce
Willis first appear fully bald in the
film I don't know I'm gonna go with the
year I was born 1989 okay 2007 Bruce
Willis was an animal what would he be I
would say he would be a hyena female
hyenas have pseudo penises which are
about 15 to 16 inches long and that's
where I envisioned for Bruce how you
doing Jeff you may call me call me Kim
Geoff hoon Kim Geoff hoon aka the
ultimate villain the roast master I'm
coming for you Bruce Willis the ultimate
hero is gonna meet the ultimate villain
today and by the way I loved you as the
carpet I heart listen man I try to do my
best
I kept slim and working out a lot
in which movie the Bruce Willis show his
Willie you don't know the color of money
the color of night the color of night
Wynwood this movie come out it came out
a while back did you know Bruce Willis
character was dead I said since when you
first watch no I was like seven and I
didn't think ahead
spoiler alert man you just ruined the
movie for a whole generation of people
that could have enjoyed the sixth sense
he was did you know though first-run
know I didn't know nobody knows that's
why you ruined it this is a quote ok let
me know whit whit whit is from ok
Zed's did baby zeds dead that would be
pulp fiction fun fiction I don't know
how I got a pole fiction I'm a
world-class assassin kid how do you
think I found out the sixth sense no he
wasn't an assassin in the sixth sense is
a psychologist lucky number Slevin oh my
sister was in that that's good she was
sexy good movie
alright police made eggs are you
classified as a human was respond
negative I am a meat popsicle that is
from actually when he appeared on
friends and I swear he said to Jennifer
Aniston actually it's from Fifth Element
but thank you not not familiar what was
Bruce Willis's high school nickname
daddy daddy's boy Bruce Willis's
nickname in high school
I don't know but to give got it points
in the world
buck-buck Thank You gamma I didn't go
thank you gift that's it thank y'all
what's the other side alright we'll just
what you talked about Louis love you
happy Rose day everybody
you